[Music]
this guys do you know this is a patreon
episode
no i did not know that oh well this is
gonna be our our
second most valuable patron episode i
think after
the phenom what did we do phenomenology
spirit yeah
all right hey big spenders my nips are
rock hard no this is going to be
extremely relevant
no matter what you uh study read think
cut that okay today
history's most famous in cell in fact
he's more successful than all other
incels combined
and the best thing to happen to 20 year
olds at least until fight club
do you want us to clap i am of course
talking about the esteemed
source of the quotes god is dead when
you stare into the abyss the abyss
stares back and what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger eke homo
freed nietzsche friedrich
fried and nitch you may have seen him in
such
television shows as the sopranos
and such movies as what was that movie i
said
little miss sunshine which is one of my
favorites
and yeah so uh what do we we have not
planned this at
all yeah because but it's going to be
epic because i think all of us know
because nietzsche is so obvious it's so
obvious to interpret them that we didn't
need to prepare
yeah i also feel it's appropriate to do
a stuff that's a joke by the way that
was a joke you don't plan things
systematically you just whip out
aphorisms one after another throw in a
little bit of woman hatred and you know
you're good
yeah throw in some something about how
you miss you missed the cast
system oh yeah of course can't forget
that
yes something about waterfalls
and i guess he wasn't technically an
insult if he died of syphilis
i think it's a conspiracy that he died
of syphilis and he actually god
just destroyed his mind because he
didn't want christians to hear what he
had to say
well tragic what do you think about what
do you think about nietzsche being 20
year old's favorite philosopher though
i think that that's accurate yeah i
think he's yeah it's like the last
10 years of his life i think a lot of
people just read him in when they're 20
and then they get really excited and
then if they're
they'll either move on and end up
following a more pragmatic career or
they just move on to like other
philosophers
or they become richard spencer and just
stay at nietzsche
yeah he did go back to live with his
mother for the last
10 years of his life but then she died
no i think i can understand why though i
mean like if you think about pretty much
any of the other major philosophers
except for plato
and a handful of others reading them
isn't exactly a lot of fun
right i mean nobody's going to go
through the critique of pure reason and
think like god i feel deeply inspired by
this it's mostly going to be like what
the [ __ ] is this saying
whereas you read nietzsche and he almost
creates a compact with you saying you
know
my readers have not yet come and they're
going to be fantastic people
and it's accessible and violent and
filled with like stuff that seems
superficially easy to understand
like i totally get it right and it
covers like a lot of the existential
issues 20 year olds deal with right
exactly you can sort of you you can tell
he's been propped up
you guys don't know this about me but i
was a an adamant
radical not a radical an adamant cantian
before i read nietzsche and then i like
really had a crisis
as it's one as it's one year old you
were [ __ ] content at first
oh yeah i was i was just eating that
[ __ ] up like
critique of practical reason i i viewed
this thing as the bible as a 20 year old
so you can't really trust 20 year olds
because they believe everything they
read
yeah of course i think it was twilight
of the idols or the gay science that i
read
which i have right here actually but i
read that and it just shattered my world
i was like morality's not real
you can't trust i had an aj soprano
moment
yeah yeah so that was like your gateway
drug to post-structuralism because then
you became like a deridian
a language philosopher guy after that
yeah i've had my
i've had my nietzsche phase my
hydrophase my derivative phase
we should also be pretty i feel like we
should be a little bit more precise too
when we talk about 20 year olds we're
really talking about 20 year old men
specifically i think it's uh worth being
specific yeah
what are they what did you say in the
spokes or thrift store thus fake zero
thirst
depending on how you translate it
there's that one woman who says disaster
destroyer like ghost without a woman
make sure you bring a whip
um and i found out later on that he
wrote the book after
his lover of sorts not even really
because she had ditched him uh
i just dumped him to go off on a
vacation with their with their mutual
buddy
and i was like uh yeah this is where
like the insult in comes out
strong that wasn't wagner's wife was it
well that was the truth that was a
tragic that's like another tragic thing
that so many 20 year old men go through
right being in the friend zone with uh
some chick that he's hanging out with
all the time but doesn't actually want
to be with him
getting friend-zoned was it lou salome
or is that yeah
well i read like some article about her
where she was describing nietzsche like
years later because she went and became
a very successful person herself
right uh particularly influenced by
psychoanalysis but
somebody used to ask her like so what
was it like spending time with nietzsche
and
the sense that you got from her she was
like smart guy but like i
was 20 years old and i wanted to go out
and have a party and basically engage in
like kinky activities across
europe and this guy was like no we need
to stay up not drink
not do all that the important thing is
to talk about philosophy
all the time yeah he was an acetic i
think
no no alcohol or drugs yeah oh that's
like the opposite of nietzsche
um and then lou salome when she was way
older
became a groomer and uh started
philandering
with rilke the jer the poet
really heidegger said he was like the
best poet and this might
this is all coming from my memory so i
haven't checked it might be full of [ __ ]
but
no she moved around um the intellectual
crowds
in uh germany for sure yeah
did you do did she do writing as well
matt i'm not sure
[Music]
i'm not sure here's in the chat here's
that famous photo of lou salome and
nietzsche and she's holding a whip for
some reason
there you go she wanted to get kink and
he was
he was exactly this is it and he's
looking a little bit afraid he was in
the mountain
yeah anyway he got spurned by her and
then
um that's why we call him an incel in
jest
although dying from syphilis he probably
contracted it during the franco-prussian
war i think is the theory that i heard
um either died of syphilis or god
destroyed his brain the jury i think
pretty much for the whole 1890s he was
out because his last
books came out in what like the 1880s
and then he went back to live with his
mother
and then his mother died and his sister
elizabeth
took over caring for him and she was
like a big anti-semitic like wagner
so she like basically made his work
into what would be uh taken up by the
nazi party and
national socialism there's actually a
video of nietzsche
in his brain dead state really oh it's
creepy as [ __ ] probably the first
philosopher on on video it's just him
like 10 pounds of mustache and he's just
like
looking off into the void the void's
probably looking back
but we don't know and he's just oh my
god
he's brain dead he looks like he looks
like someone you just have to like spoon
yogurt into his open mouth for the rest
of his life have you guys heard this
other bit of hearsay and then we'll get
to it
but all this hearsay is fun um i don't
know if this is true or not it sounds
like
american propaganda but i heard
from somewhere sometime along the line
that
whereas american soldiers carried the
bible or they were all given a bible
as part of their like service kit
meanwhile the german soldiers were given
a copy of
thus bake their thustra that's a good
question
i don't know really i mean this sounds
like oh it's like the forces of good
against the i feel easily i feel like we
could easily verify that by doing a
quick google search
yeah that's a little too nice i almost
don't want to know the answer though i
just want to like believe in this
american
propaganda we're the moral ones
and they read nietzsche it's a little
too nice yeah we had we gave our
soldiers morphine and they gave their
soldiers
which one was worse does it kill you
right
and if you get addicted [ __ ] you deal
with the boy but the fact like just the
thought that every german
every like vermont german soldier is
like
thinking of themselves as this uh
triumphing
over man conquering uh the world the
ubermensch
in the name of nazism which nietzsche is
associated with because of his
[ __ ] sister but yeah that's an
important concept we'll definitely have
to uber mention
that one
[Laughter]
i'm becoming a dad not really but i'm
practicing
all right where do we want to start um
that's a good question
like we we should separate there's two
interpretations here at least
because we're making fun of him for
being the 20 year old's favorite
philosopher which is legit because he's
so accessible butcher is multiple but
heidegger
like heidegger's longest book is on
nietzsche delize writes on nietzsche
foucault's entire method is modeled
after
nietzsche's derridas and denisha
especially that earlier work on the on
the
uh truth and morality right on truth and
lying in the non-moral sense
was a major that's the one where he
delivered his
truth is a mobile army of metaphors
metonomies
and anthropomorphisms that was a big one
yeah historiography religious studies
theology environmentalism there's an
environmentalist nature there's a queer
female maybe
maybe you should start all kinds there's
a far right nietzsche
here i'll just i'll start maybe we
should start start reading uh the
beginning of
uh delizi's book on nietzsche okay the
concept of genealogy
nietzsche's most general project is the
introduction of the concepts of sense
and value into philosophy
it is clear that modern philosophy has
largely lived off nietzsche
but not perhaps in the way in which he
would have wished nietzsche made no
secret of the fact that philosophy of
sense and values had to be a critique
one of the principal motifs of
nietzsche's work is that kant had not
carried out a true critique because he
was not able to pose the
problem of critique in terms of values
and what has happened in modern
philosophy is that the theory of values
has given
rise to new conformism and new forms of
submission
so for what what's he saying there
something like um
like for neat for for critique is
oriented towards
what we can know about the world and
truth
and morality is just one of those sorts
of transcendental truths
as in if if we're operating well when he
says values i don't think he's talking
about
moral values specifically
well it's christian moral values and the
slave morality and ethics like that's
all
sort of tied up in values like what we
what we hold
dear right and truth becomes a value in
a sense
i think i have a different
interpretation i'm not sure if he means
uh
values in terms of morality precisely
alone like that's the subject of
the trans valuation of values or
whatever but for him
um the notion of values is more
generally historical
or historicist i should say in
interpreting
history and that values don't that are
like everything's a value there are no
facts
really because everything has to be
placed in its
historical hermeneutic i think so
everything's interpreted
is nietzsche's line whereas kant's value
system
is saying there's things that are not
interpreted like the uh there are also
no
truth separate from human perception
that's another thing
he's a big aesthetics guy aesthetics in
the old sense
he's a radical historicist well
the way i see it actually because he
sometimes characterized himself as
an anti-platonist right and denigrated
christianity as platonism for the masses
right
uh but if you enter one way to interpret
plato and i think this is the way
nietzsche does that is
plato has this very interesting theory
which is that all good things
and i mean good colloquially go together
right uh truth is related to justice
which is related to beauty which is
related to eternity
uh which is related to god uh and all
these things can kind of be synthesized
together right
and the course of western philosophy has
essentially been to show
that these things don't not only don't
go together uh but
they all might be empty uh or
self-justifying right
and so the modernist revolution from
hume onward basically says
well actually there's this stark
distinction between facts and values and
you might be able to know facts
but value judgments uh are independent
of that and they're primarily based on
it's like uh subjective orientations
affect and so on and so forth
uh and nietzsche's total critique seems
to be saying that actually even the
notion of truth now that we've abandoned
our platonism
needs to come into scrutiny uh and he
actually refers to this kind of platonic
language of values as being together
i think to kind of highlight how far
we've come uh from this original idea
that
all good things are kind of unity yeah
truth
morality aesthetics goodness all of this
is
a conceit that comes out of history and
a particular
history that's the thesis of the
genealogy of morals
so just to give our listeners a i guess
a mental template here
nietzsche has a long [ __ ] list
um judeo christianity if you want to
lump those two together
are on the [ __ ] list liberalism is on
the [ __ ] list
any philosophy that is after plato
is on the [ __ ] list democracy
democracy's on the [ __ ] list
social science and so what's the problem
with all this stuff yeah socialism is on
the [ __ ] list
yeah communism science everybody except
for like
homeric heroes like achilles he likes
paul's hair
he he likes the samurai he likes the
vikings he likes the roman napoleon
likes
the he likes napoleon he likes homer and
he likes the old
greek tragedies he liked wagner but then
he started
hating wagner but he fell in love with
wagner's wife
so i think i i yeah i mean it seems like
a lot of these critiques come from this
place that
nietzsche always wants to invoke this
category of like life
life affirming like some sort of
instincts for life some sort of vitality
um i don't know like well how how would
you guys like it's it's a bit ambiguous
but that's often what he invokes he says
that these other things like
morality they're like suppressing like
the true
instinct for life or this vitality or
this kind of like um
i guess ability for the human to to
achieve
a kind of self mastery or an overcoming
that's where the idea of the over man
i think comes from it is it's a little
bit like
stoicism and nihilism put together like
it's a
it's a it's acknowledging that suffering
is inevitable
and we shouldn't base our world view on
trying to avoid
suffering and on the other hand that
it's a celebration
a sensual celebration of the sort of
living life to its fullest yeah i'll
talk about like he's the wild man in
that sense
true human instincts that's why i think
20 year olds like this is actually i
think the part where like the 20 year
olds get attracted to them right because
i think everything we said up to this
point
it's like maybe not necessarily clear
like well why would 20 year olds like it
but it's because of this claim right
that all these things that you're being
told
are [ __ ] and they're like hiding and
suppressing
our true potential to be these like
self-overcoming like
[ __ ] awesome like i don't know like
like alpha alpha males like alpha male
dawns exactly like 300 every zack snyder
movie
is like acting out this impulse to be
nichian
oh yeah exactly zack snyder's a secret
20 year old like the movie 300 or all
these stupid batman they're like
no this is a movie it's so gritty it's
dark it's for like real men
or even batman versus superman right i
mean the whole thing that they go
through
and that in this really cheesy way is
like what does it mean for a superman to
be on earth right
somebody who's just better at everything
than everybody
nietzsche was kind of like an atheist
too like he gave this
voice to atheism and that's what i felt
like a lot of people feel like they when
they pick up
someone like christopher hitchens and
they get this sort of secularist
world view that is against religion like
that was one of the things that
attracted me like nietzsche could
articulate a worldview that was
completely separate like not even when
you read
german idealism you get the sense that
it's just christianity disguised as
philosophy
but when you read nietzsche you get the
sense that he's really
trying to articulate something that's
completely separate from christian
values
and has nothing to do with it and is in
many ways
against and i think one of the distinct
things about it is also how
he doesn't just historicize a lot of
value systems uh whatever those happen
to be
but he also psychologizes them and i
think this speaks to eric's point right
where
the only time when he seems to make
value judgments uh if you even want to
call it that
uh are aesthetic judgments about health
and sickness
and it's always related back to
biological metaphors right um
so he tends to evaluate moral
philosophies
uh not in the way that we would do it
but by saying that
this philosophy is sick right it's a
kind of pathology that would be adopted
by unhealthy or weak people right
exactly who are unable to deal with
their resentment through aggression uh
so they do it by
adopting a slave mentality right um
incidentally he was a very sick man
himself too
like yeah yeah
he was ill he had to quit university his
post and he went on disability he got a
disability pension
after he left his university post
back to eric's point about this uh
secularism or
uh atheism or a self-proclaimed
antichrist
the way the way that we have this like
sam harris that crew
they say oh we just don't need god and
then like everything's fine we can just
like be
moral rational intelligent etc
as the and like atheism's just fine but
nietzsche is very good at understanding
psychologically no atheism is traumatic
atheism means you can only create values
history history's not going anywhere
it's this eternal recurrence everything
is
only what you make it and 100 of the
responsibility for that is on you
so it's not a happy atheism it's not
like oh we got rid of god the tyrant is
dead
it's like now you're [ __ ] alone on
this rock
you little monkey but there is a joy
there is a joy
bro either is he nietzsche's not a logic
bro he's not saying we don't need
theism we just need reason he's not
saying that either because that's what
those
that's what like the hitchins dawkins
sam harris types
are like reason logic right nietzsche's
not for that reason
for nietzsche comes from the same place
that christianity comes from
it has that ascetic self-denying core
so for a reason it's simply objective
reason i got to keep my feelings out of
it
and for christianity it's more obvious
i think you're exactly right eric and i
think if he were alive today and he saw
the logic bros or the
uh radical skeptics or youtube atheist
right
uh he'd probably find them just as
annoying as he found people like jon
stewart mill
right because his mind that they want to
do is keep the trappings of christian
culture
its emphasis on reason its emphasis on
logic its emphasis
uh on you know the moral and value of
everybody
uh and or at least objectively truth you
know
advancing human welfare and they want to
just check the theology and secularize
it
and nietzsche would say you can't do
that you know uh
if you say that there's no god and
there's no value to human life
why the [ __ ] do you think that it's
important to actually advance human
welfare
right uh on what basis do you make that
kind of claim
victory you've been trying to talk yeah
i was just gonna say like so
is it the case that there's um like a
kind of like there is
a kind of self-denial but i also see it
there being actually like a quite a
joyful
and hopeful aspect to nietzsche which is
not so
which is that we don't have to deny
anymore like we can just be we can like
let loose and uh uncover
these true instincts for life and that
like only like a true culture with the
right kind of values can can reveal
so like in some ways there's like he's
he's kind of like
um i i often read them as kind of like
sneaking in values through like almost
an empirical human nature claim about
like uh like you know that the human
beings are an organism that that there
is
the best there is like a state of the
human animal
that is the exhibitive state of like the
best version of a human being
and all these things that we use to try
to suppress
and like lie to ourselves and have this
morality that's supposed to be like a
it's just a way of like hiding what we
are
which is an instantiation of this like
will to power or something this
this process this like mindless godless
process
but but like when we try to deny it and
lie to us we get sick
right we get sick a culture that makes
us deny this
we become a sick culture and the goal is
supposed to be
to uncover and let loose this energy
this vitality
that is like our true instincts for life
as an animal so there's kind of like a
so the values come from this like
empirical claim
almost of like the what the universe is
and that the animal has its best version
where its instincts are being unleashed
if that makes sense
i just want to add to this by saying
that i'm now picturing like george
bataille or michelle pico
in the middle of like some hardcore bdsm
and like
just ramming every kind of thing into
every conceivable orifice like
covered in like bodily fluids and like
their [ __ ]
person is like is it right and they're
like doesn't [ __ ] matter god is dead
okay
there is no right or wrong just give in
to your animal but there's a joyfulness
to it right like that's why the gay
science right like the joyful science i
mean there is like
there's like a joyfulness to unleashing
we can let go of this now and we can
just be ourselves thinking about all the
kinks
there's a relief there's a release now
that pictures now that picture's in all
of our heads so thanks for that
he wants us to get there he wants us to
understand that
morality and values are historical
and that truth is well on the one hand
it's a lie but on
it's a useful lie yeah the truth is if
you can understand that
then we can be gay about it we can have
a gay science we can be cheerful
we can be happy good and this is in a
way like the noble values right as
opposed to the slave values the nobles
are happy-go-lucky they live in the
moment they don't sacrifice
the now to the future well they yeah
they don't sacrifice the future
to the now i think they just go for it
okay homo
yeah i think that actually points to
another really interesting feature of
nietzsche's work that you don't actually
see
in many philosophers although you do see
it all the time in a lot of the
um authors that nietzsche was influenced
like people like dostoevsky and it's
also president heidegger
uh which is that nietzsche is a moody
[ __ ] right um
some days he writes up and he's talking
about the joyful science
or the gay science and how it is that
now that we're liberated from god we can
allow
our instincts to take over without
needing to fall into resentment
um and pathological dissociation like we
did before but other days he wakes up
and it's exactly the way victor
describes he feels
nihilistic and he feels upset and he
says you know there's no meaning to
anything
and this is captured in the spokes era
thursday i think very nicely because
sarah thursday basically goes on
all these weird odysseys uh and
nietzsche must have been one of the very
first philosophers in the western
tradition that i can think of at least
who really takes the idea of mood
seriously you know what i mean uh he
says you know
every other philosopher likes to
characterize us this way or that way
uh when really you know we have
multitudes within us as walt whitman
would say
right you know some days i want to go
destroy things other days i want to
be a pleasant person and get along with
others other days i just feel like [ __ ]
and i want to like say get the [ __ ] away
and i want the world to leave me alone
right
there's a there's a good case to be made
that he was like severely
manic depressive because you can see his
mania and his depression both in his
work
and then there's like the book ek homo
and all the chapter titles are like
why i am so wise why i write such good
books
why by his first interpreters his first
interpreters took him more
as like a stance an attitude or a
disposition
rather than a philosopher too his first
like the modernists
because obviously nietzsche died in 1900
and that's the big
that's sort of you're into modernism now
they read him as an attitude they didn't
look at him as a philosopher
and he was one of those philosophers who
well he wrote poetically
right there's an aesthetic pleasure to
just reading his books
it's not like hot where it's very dry
and very
logical and everything is sort of
constructed
in this nice neat way no his way he's
he's poetic
he's outrageous he's funny he's like
yeah yes one second he's like tickling
your balls the next second he's kicking
you in the teeth
it's it's it's kind of a ride just
reading him
he really like reproduces what he wants
to get in that aesthetic experience of
just
reading this sort of beautiful weird
philosophy
and this aphoristic style that was not
taken seriously at the time but i think
that's refreshing interesting stuff
just just just to give an example
because we're talking about his
aphorisms
i just this is at random i've opened it
up but it's a nice punctuation
what matters is whether i am
acknowledged to be right
i am much too right and he who laughs
best today
will also laugh last
[Laughter]
yeah that's funny there you go laughter
is a big thing in his but every book
he there's something about laughter in
it and it's some kind of abstract
laughter like the i don't know the fates
laughing at us
i think it's like an absurdist sort of
laughter it's not like
it's like the laughter and rap videos
when they start and they're like
it's nothing funny happened it's just
like i'm so
confident and rich that i just laugh i
think you laugh in the face of fate
would be a big thing for him he's a he's
very fatalistic
but he embraces it he he tries to get us
to embrace
the uh slings and arrows right he
doesn't want us to
sort of get into this christian mode of
thinking we're like if i just endure
this
everything will be better the judgment
they'll i'll have eternity
and all the wealth and riches in heaven
like he thinks that that's a cop out and
you're not living your life if you're
if you're thinking of the world as
fallen and
disastrous and the uh the shadow of the
valley of death type approach to that's
kind of refreshing though and
again i think testifies to his appeal to
particularly young people
right because when you read a lot of
these philosophers they don't write like
people
uh in the sense of being a complete
human alter human being
right uh you know can't kind of rid sits
there and he's like these are my
thoughts
about the subject matter here's counter
argument a b c
you know aristotle and thomas aquinas
are like here's proposition one
scolium you know blah blah blah blah uh
and if you read nietzsche you do get
kind of a sense like if you read
kierkegaard or for that matter if you
read
tolstoy or dostoevsky or whoever it
happens to be that you kind of
get a sense for his personality right
like you can almost imagine what it'd be
like
if he were at a bar and he were to walk
in and sit down and be like
i'm not ordering any drinks and you
shouldn't either and be like [ __ ] off
bro
and then you'd have like a long
conversation with them and you'd never
know which nietzsche you were gonna get
because maybe he'd storm in and be like
i had a fantastic day today
you know i've climbed mountains that
none of before or maybe really depressed
and i think that's refreshing right like
you kind of get a sense for who he was
as a person
i think he would be a nightmare to
actually be friends with though
probably he's angsty as [ __ ] probably
and arrogant megalomaniac as [ __ ] no
arrogant as [ __ ] yeah he had to open
making
friends uh into enemies right like
there's no doubt about it i think he uh
i think he wrote i think maybe he kind
of wrote in a way i was just thinking
about this when you were talking matt
like
like maybe like hit the the the style of
writing is almost maybe analogous to the
way he thinks you should like live life
that what like a true life is
where it's like the kantian way of
writing it's like so i was going to make
a comment before about how i think
another thing i play in his sort of like
ontology is
this in this relationship he has to like
distance to the way things keep you away
from your true instincts for life
and one of those is the way like science
it like tries to formalize things and
like to divide things up and he's like
now you're like distanced from the thing
you're not like united there's like this
whole thing where
uh there's supposed to be a relationship
there's like an in like when you're in
the world you have like this horizon of
meaning that's only possible
when you're like engaged in the world
and in touch with like your instincts
and i think
i wonder if to some extent like the
style of writing speaks to
the way he thinks your life should be
experienced as this like
this vitality this this like this ride
of of like of eruptions of emotion and
feeling and it's like these other
formalistic ways they're just keeping
you from that truth
of like what human life should be no i
think if you look at the kind of authors
that he admired
right dostoevsky voltaire um
shakespeare yeah shakespeare right i
mean all of them have that kind of
vitality to their writing
and you know express kind of panoramic
vision of the human personality
that's less judgmental shall we say of
people's idiosyncrasies
uh or their failures to live up to their
own standards more willing to
acknowledge their hypocrisies
and so on uh and maybe in some senses we
could say that
a lot of his philosophy or the way that
he wrote is an attempt to react against
this because
there was nobody who's better at put
downs than nietzsche right
i remember he was talking about hegel uh
i think it was in
one of his pieces on wagner where he was
talking about the birth of tragedy and
he said
my earlier books to me read as
offensively hegelian
and when i say offensively hegelian i
mean the rod of it just like comes up
into my nose
and the stench of it like makes me feel
sick to my stomach
and you're just like man he clearly
wrote that just like sitting down
he's like this is a perfect chance just
to get like a [ __ ] sick dig
at hegel um because you know tagline
bodies exactly that's also a
rationalistic method
and he means the dialectic too his
thinking was too dialectical which if
you go back to one of our earlier
episodes you can learn all about that
yeah
but i mean if you look at the figures
that he admired right that's the point
you know
he doesn't like people who sit there and
try to rationalize uh or dissociate
themselves from their own
vitalist and vital impulses right even
when they're uh they push people in
different direction right
um and i think there's a kind of virtue
for that also right because you do get a
more
complete vision uh of the uglier sides
of human beings as well as the more
noble sides in his work
that's the core of asceticism is
self-denial you deny yourself
these pleasures you deny like what does
it mean to be ascetic
it it kind of means like it mean like
this is his bad kind of morality
is the ascetic kind of morality but he
wasn't anything
he was an aesthetic i think it matters
why
you are doing that action not not what
you're doing right
but like the noble and the ascetic are a
kind of
opposite in his work like the noble
kind of you just kind of do what you
want he talks about nobility
as as like good and bad
and good is you know like
going out and conquering somebody and
bringing back a whole load of
treasure and booty and slaves and
whatever
and and bad is just derivative of that
you don't you you fail to do that
whereas the other kind of morality that
ascetic morality
where the good is being weak
but yeah he was an ascetic in his life
as like not drinking and all this stuff
um and not taking medicine for his
headaches
but what he hates is that the the
ascetic moralizes to everybody else and
says
you have to give up everything good too
like christianity christianity's the
worst offender you have to
give up sex yeah you can you have to be
married you have to follow all these
institutions
but you have to do it to yourself and
then enjoy it and to him this is just
like really disgusting that
you're compelled to follow these rules
that make your life
worse and then be celebrated for that
you're celebrating mediocrity
because you're a a wimp also i think
that his form of asceticism right so
those things that he's denying himself
alcohol
medicine it makes sense because those
are things that are interfering
with like with the inner vitality that
he has as a human being so like to me it
makes sense that he'd be like
don't do those things just like the way
christianity masks the truth of like the
human
the the uh the vital human uh it's like
also i could imagine him saying alcohol
and medicine does the same thing i think
actually has a really freudian insight
just rip off
pills for a second he often claims that
when people pathologically try to
dissociate
from their seemingly baser instincts
uh they're not actually going to
disappear they're just going to
take on a new and more idolatrous form
right uh and i think one of the most
pregnant passages in his entire work
uh where when he's analyzing tertullian
who's christian state
um and tertullian describes how it is
that
after a life of sitting there living in
a world of sin where bad people seem to
get ahead
uh denying yourself all your pleasures
one of the great joys that's going to
exist in heaven
is all the righteous are going to live
with god and they're going to be able to
stare down
into hell and enjoy the suffering of the
people and the hell
which is probably going to include a lot
of the people who mocked the christians
in real life right
uh i know that justice has been done uh
and you know
nietzsche points to this and says well
there you go this is what your
love and compassion uh and dissociating
from your base your instincts does to
you
they're not gone uh you've now just
projected them into a cosmology
and said that god is now going to punish
people for you
and you're going to sit there and be
able to take satisfaction from knowing
that their suffering is going to be a
journal
and it's a pretty interesting insight
right
yeah that's that's it it's based in uh
it's based in he calls it he says things
like well it's translated as
rancor or vitriol like the slave ethic
is based on hating basically like
they're haters that's what he basically
thinks the entire
judeo critic christian tradition is is
like taylor swift was the best uh
in the world down with her whole like
haters gonna hate hate hate hate you
know
because like you're you're like let's
pretend we are the
aristocracy and we are
subduing these people and eventually
this priestly class breaks off from us
and
goes to the people and starts to
convince them like hey isn't what
they're doing
kind of wrong isn't what they're doing
like isn't their strength
and their dominance over you kind of an
evil thing
yeah and grief is this sort of example
of like the hawk comes and takes the
lamb
and the and the lambs think the hawk is
evil
because the hawk and he says no the hawk
is just being the hawk
but the slave morality is about making
this whole hateful cosmology
of why your your your enemies are
bad and you are good because you're weak
and you don't
hurt other people and you you're just
meek and humble
and that's like that's his whole thing
and
really all of that sort of christian
goodness is disguised
vitriol for i mean this is him not me
i'm i'm sounding passionate but
that's what he said like the whole
judeo-christian tradition is is based on
hatred
and wanting to see the other people
we're talking about like the blessed or
the meek for they shall inherit the
earth so now
the the weak instead of just being weak
little little like
losers now they're the blessed now they
they have the reward coming to them and
he was not he was extremely
i mean he speaks against it because he
thinks that this version has taken over
but he said this invention like this
christian
or judeo-christian invention was the
most
impressive example of will to power in
history because the weak
actually took over the entire world
which is
exactly the opposite of what you'd
expect to happen i mean in the
antichrist he used
he says and i think this is a remarkable
quote right uh that jesus was the only
foe who was actually worthy of him
which is pretty impressive when you
think of the fact that nietzsche did not
like a lot of people
right um but he did also really argue
that you want
good enemies or powerful enemies since
it's only by testing yourself against
them that you can become stronger and i
think
is admiration for jesus if you want to
call it that is precisely because of
what you're talking about right jesus
had a message
uh he was killed and yet despite the
fact that he was killed and everyone
thought he's gone
uh billions of people rose up in his
name and the weak overcame the strong
for time
uh and he has this remarkable passage
somewhere i think it might have been in
the antichrist but i'm not sure
where he talks about pity um in the kind
of way that eric was describing right
where he said
think about how good it feels to pity
someone else right
uh you can sit there and not only do you
feel morally superior
but you can also sit there and think
thank god i'm not them
right uh not only am i better for them
because i feel bad for them
uh but i'm also not them and that
demonstrates my own superiority
right and he says when you think about
this this goes to show you
just how the life-denying instinct of
christianity was able to create
all of these weird pathological uh
propensities right
and sometimes he almost seems to admire
them i mean he has this amazing
comment in the genealogy of gnarls where
he says yeah christianity [ __ ] a lot
of people up by giving them all these
weird pathologies
but these mythologies also deepen the
human soul right because
now we have to deal with all these
neuroses about guilt and pity and
do i actually genuinely feel bad for
this person
and you know you can look at a
dostoyevsky novel and there's all kinds
of interesting things um
in there and that's the reason why right
and
like you gotta we're saying that
nietzsche is against judeo-christianity
um and i think we should qualify that
because yeah he's got
nothing but good things to say for jesus
because jesus was
like 100 committed to his cause until
death and that's an admirable quality
what he really hates
are the priests he also speaks his other
hero is king david
from the old testament because are the
what's the right word for that hebrew
bible
anyway but king david was a warrior and
a poet so he's like the most beautiful
person in history because he's an
artist and like a conqueror so he's not
like opposed to the whole tradition he's
really opposed to
the priests and what priests do with it
and how priests like manage
people and as eric was saying they sow
this discontent
this discontentment yeah and i think
ultimately well i think what's
interesting is
i is um the way
the way like he talks about how the like
christianity is an expression of will to
power
right so like that's kind of interesting
because he condemns like the way
it's directed but he also in other
places
values the will to power as being like
the guide to the truth so there's like
it almost seems like there's like a
contradiction between well christianity
is an expression of the world to power
then
you should like it because it's the will
to power like expressing itself
but you're saying that that's like a
worse will to power than the will to
power that
i guess it's like so i don't know if
anyone wanted to like pick up on that
right so he'll never say like this is
bad christianity's bad
he will just say i don't like
christianity he's an iconoclast and he's
saying like
we lost this beautiful greek world where
of tragedy and heroes
because of these like weak people took
over but he respects that it took over
right he's
he's he's he does make but he does make
like value claims about like like the
you know the the vitality of the
organism of the human that like
christianity by and large is like
somehow
like doing even though it is an
expression of will to power it's also
somehow suppressing
some aspect of of of the human animal
that that he doesn't seem to like
pill says this and he and he doesn't say
christianity's bad in the moral sense
right since of course
we're supposed to live beyond good and
evil but there are other passages where
he does say particularly in the
genealogy of morals that
look we have to look at his christianity
from a historical standpoint
and recognize not just that it's
admirable in some sense because the weak
overcame the strong
but again because the contributions of
christianity at its best deepened
the human psyche or the human soul right
by forcing it to deal
with problems and inclinations that
weren't
explicit before right and now we're in a
crisis because sometimes he almost seems
to write
and this goes to show you to the moody
disability like we've fallen from an
authentic christian impulse uh where
people really had to wrestle with these
problems
uh back in you know the days of christ
and now what we get is watered down
christianity out of democracy and
socialism
and cantianism right uh where people
just want you know to be christian
without having to buy into
all the kind of hard difficult stuff
about god uh that people had to deal
with back in
the ancient world he was a great he was
a very great admirer of saint augustine
and i think he said something like
augustine was the first psychologist
i might be misremembering that but no
he's not against christians
he's against again i mean like
thoughtful
christianity he's against this rule
heard christianity
yeah well he does have some pretty harsh
things to say
in the genealogy of of morality
like he does say that jesus was
basically like a trap
planned by the jews to get everyone onto
their side
he does say he does say that in in the
first essay
and he also clarifies in the first essay
because the first essay is called of
good and bad and good and evil
and good and evil is what he's trying to
get beyond
good and bad is what the aristocratic
nobility class had
bad was derivative of good but in beyond
good and evil the good and evil part is
the
christian morality because evil
is derivative of good right because
everything that's
good for the aristocrats becomes evil
for the christians and well for the
priestly class
and then the jews invent christianity in
order to get everybody on their side and
give this sort of
he he calls it a trap really he just
said like he respects it all like this
is that placating move right like even
when we read walter benjamin we're like
the death of the aura he really respects
the aura and stuff but he never really
says that he just says this is what's
happening uh it's failing it's fading
away
and really christianity is like an
extension of judaism
and it was this symbol of the cross this
monstrous
concept of a dead god is was a powerful
symbol that they they use because the
priestly class is one
there's no worse enemies to have than
the priests they are the biggest haters
in history
and they are also craftier than nobility
so their
their hatred their nursing their wounds
will always win out
over the cheerful happy-go-lucky gay
nobility
right who who don't who they respect
their enemies they respect bad
things and respect is already a bridge
to love
but the christians they hate and they
disguise it as love and that's the
difference here's this amazing passage
though about
jesus right uh and christianity it says
think of how powerful this gesture was
because
if you think about the greek world the
gods occasionally did suffer in the
greek world but they were immortal and
kind of
operated in an eternal realm uh beyond
human suffering right
whereas what the christian myth did so
poignantly uh is
precisely it kind of made god into a
loser right
uh you know if you think about the story
of jesus god jesus is a loser right you
know
he's born he preaches he gets a few
followers uh then the romans turn them
in
everyone decides that they don't like
jesus anymore since the authority has
said that he's failed
uh then he gets crucified and there's
only a few people who bother to go to
his funeral right
uh and the accomplishment historically
of christianity in some senses
is by recognizing that this guy even
though he is a loser
uh is a powerful symbol to all the weak
everywhere right because it says that
eventually he will rise again and he
will inherit the earth and so too will
you
uh and any number of greek philosophers
would look at that and be bewildered by
this because they'd be like well this
isn't a powerful symbol it doesn't have
a kind of noble
bearing to it um but for you know the
millions of disenfranchised people
across the globe obviously
that's not what they're looking for
since a life of nobility is so far
removed from them uh
and yet this figure you know it looks
and acts exactly like them
right and this thing about poisoning
values i just want to explain in case
any of our listeners are not with us
here
um but in christianity you can just look
at what are the sins gluttony
avarice pride and these are
values for the aristocracy because
you're not you're
pride is just you know i'm stronger than
everybody else and i know that
gluttony is just you have enough food to
eat and no one else does
and the priests want you to share it
avarice
is like you're you're greedy but
if you're if you were the you know king
on the hill
why should you not be greedy you won
you're winning
um so this turning of all aristocratic
goodness
you know greed avarice now it becomes a
sin to be those things
and yeah that's his objection yeah also
last you know it's worth
it you know because yeah you can't get
laid no one can get laid now
yeah well i think that's exactly right
it's really difficult to actually
pin down what he has to say uh on any
given matter canonically
i think for exactly this reason right
you know nietzsche's not a dialectician
like you know i said he seems to have
this kind of
idea that hegelianism is wayfish uh
and kind of cuckold uh cuckish and you
know uh
everybody's trying to have everything
both ways right uh but he does seem to
unseem to say
things like wow on the one hand you know
i'm offended by this because it doesn't
have a kind of normal aura to it
on the other hand you do have to admire
the fact that these people
came to inherit the earth and they were
able to overcome the strong despite the
fact that
the strong by definition are stronger
than the weak right
so nichianism is epic and the rest of it
is cut so why don't we shift here and
talk a little bit
about how did he influence philosophy
so strongly and we could talk about
people like freud
or foucault um heidegger obviously
wrote his longest book on nietzsche um
how do you how how does this get applied
richard spencer
existentialism too existentialism yeah
we have this like
how did his method and specifically his
historicity saying everything is in
history
and history is not going anywhere how
did that uh play out in the 20th century
so he's he's also lumped in with marx
and freud
in this hermeneutics of suspicion like
these guys
are the inventors of hermeneutics of
suspicion which is essentially like
an academic way of saying don't take
things that face value
that's one of those things right like
like goodness as a moral virtue
is something that we should be
suspicious of because you're saying well
what is goodness good for who does it
work for
and we have to look at it historically
and do this sort of genealogical
approach
right where did it come from it came
from the ancient world
and was passed down through all the
transformations we've been talking about
where originally it referred to class
and then it came to refer
to something more like like uh being
being good as something about being weak
and being dominated
and then it came through it came to be
completely detached from its
historical point and it became something
metaphysical and he doesn't like that
because metaphysics
kind of spells this detachment from
reality for him
yeah i know i think that's exactly right
i mean but i don't think i could really
put it better right this notion that
uh morality and value systems uh aren't
eternal and they don't exist in some
kind of metaphysical heaven
uh the way that plato conceived of them
uh but they're embedded in the life
practices and the kind of natural
history of
mankind um it'd actually seem i think
like kind of commonsensical to us now
since so many people have internalized
this idea right
uh but at the time certainly in the 19th
century this is a radical notion right
what do you mean that our values
don't come from heaven or they're not
eternal or they're not universally valid
and they're still we're still in the
midst of these kind of debates today
right
so i would say yeah i think that that's
a good place to
to to flag the influence that nietzsche
had
on existentialism right because i think
i think existentialism kind of takes
that claim and runs with it right that
like okay like values aren't
uh like divine from above right and in
some ways like we kind of have to figure
them out on our own we have to we have
to like and of course
nietzsche had something different than
what a lot of the existentialists had in
mind which is that
you know there's going to be some uh
these great philosophers of the future
who are going to come and like determine
these great values for everybody but i
think existentialism is sort of picked
up on that idea
and and said you know we have to figure
these things out on our own and and
make the values that make sense for us
sartre
you know the marxist revolution will
save us and then like and also like the
anxiety
of life and like that we're not going to
have anybody hold our hand that like
life is like
a difficult and a contingent and a susp
imbued with specificities that we can't
subsume under some moral system
existentialism i think is picking up on
that and saying we have to like
live in that and be okay with it yeah i
think we've mentioned it before but the
mantra of
existentialism is is existence
precedes essence right and
for nietzsche there is no sort of
neutral subject behind the actions when
we
act when we do things when we think
things and even this is
he actually links this to science too
he'll say he'll say like it's energy
that moves things
and he says no there's no distinction
between the energy that moves things and
the thing being moved
just like there's no neutral agent
behind
the willing or the doing right like to
do
is to be it's the same thing for
nietzsche
i always find that a little bit
problematic though because that almost
seems
like metaphysics though i mean i think
this is where we get into inescapable
problem with him right which is that if
you say
i'm a post-metaphysical philosopher but
then you say
ultimately all existence is energy or
all existence is will to power it's like
wow
it's hard to think of a more grandiose
metaphysical statement than that
right oh he's sneaking in metaphysics
for sure he's saying he's saying science
he's a philologist right so he's saying
when science talks this way they are
a dupe of linguistic habits that's what
he's going to say
we are treating the grammatical subject
as
something metaphysical and real and
behind existence
but he's saying these are he's a
philologist right and all through his
works he's tracing terms back to their
origin
he's bringing up what is good and french
what is good in this language what is
good
in that language and they all have this
common sort of root in class
consciousness
right the good the good are the upper
class and the bad or the
the common class but they make that they
reverse that they turn that around
so for him like doing and
the subject of the doing if we regard
the subject of the doing
as something separate from the doing
then what we're doing is we're falling
prey to our
language habits basically we're reifying
we're hypostasizing
all those fancy words but that's that's
the i think that's the thrust of
existentialism is that you exist
and you do things before essences emerge
before things are what they are
they just have to be for a little while
you know one of my favorite quotes of
all time by him is
uh we are not yet rid of god because we
still have
faith in grammar yeah
like holds the rest of the world
together that we still believe in
um and then yeah yeah his attention to
language is actually quite surprising
when you look at it and
look at how many of his arguments are
grounded in
language right and this this is one of
the really
influential things about him you're
going to see this come back in heidegger
in a big way
taking taking words and then looking at
their greek origins
so what is presence for heidegger
presence is perusia where does that come
from that comes from the
greek metaphysical tradition right like
this is a huge
thing and we get into this sort of
language determines reality kind of
arguments but what nietzsche and
heidegger and some of those guys are
trying to do is
is weird like it's strange it's using
etymologies
and philology in order to like sort of
explode the taken for grantedness
of these terms we use truth and the
subject
and what is good and bad and he's using
the philological argument
like in a way almost like more than we
probably
should be because like maybe maybe words
and etymologies don't make that good
at the basis they're not so good at the
basis of our arguments
but and this is called historicism right
and it's uh turned into what's called an
archaeology of knowledge by
uh foucault foucault i think grounds a
little bit more in practice
than just language as uh nietzsche does
but for instance
heidegger and darida following heidegger
uh adopt this method and use this method
in order to
like nietzsche precursor deconstruction
by doing his philology
that that's what i was going to say
actually because one of the ways that
you can interpret daredevil particularly
like the early dared of the 1960s and
70s
uh as a result like reacting precisely
against the kind of
platonic conceit that you would
sometimes see
in say positivistic approaches to
language right which is that
basically whatever word that you say you
talk about has some kind
of real um
object that is pointy to in the external
world
right uh so you can draw one comparison
between the kind of
platonic essence of a thing uh in
language
uh with this kind of material
instantiation in the empirical world
right and he says no that's not true
right i mean we can't
get past the idea that there's some kind
of transcendent sign that tells you the
way that the world really is and
recognize that there's just
a collection of different signs that are
essentially all relating to one another
uh and we play with them right and we
play with them in a variety of ways
sometimes
when i say apple it means one thing
sometimes when i say apple it means
uh you know the company right on my ipad
or my iphone or whatever it happens to
be
right and all of this is legitimate and
we should stop trying to suggest
uh that all things need to be tied up
neatly with a bow
words don't simplify facts they point to
values
right everything's values and they have
a history
and they have our actual history of
usage and
our thought right like when he says that
the first metaphor is when we name
something
right and in that naming we introduce a
gap
and that gap is the subject object gap
right because when we take something
into our language
then it can can become the subject of a
sentence or the object of a sentence
right
the apple the apple i threw an apple
right so i'm the subject
and the apple is the object right we we
introduce that gap that's that gap that
kant could never
solve the problem of right between the
subject and the object
and nietzsche's whole argument is yeah
that's because it's a
grammatical construct and then the
second metaphor
for him is when we use these words and
we forget
originally where they come from what
their experiential grounding was
where we first encountered that thing
that we named it becomes second metaphor
right
truth yeah then just a second because
we're talking a little bit abstractly
but
um oh by the way we have a patron who's
a linguist and she always
fact checks our etymology studies so
shout out to her i'm gonna try to do
this right
but we're talking about truth as like
this origin word of metaphysics and when
you think of true
you think of our truth as something
abstract something that is
out there and we talk about how we
understand and get to the truth but if
you trace the etymology
of the word true back to old english and
prior
it means tree and tree
becomes the word for like firmness or
whatever the adjective for firmness
so but it means drew or drew is the word
and
we have the word druid that comes from
the same word for
for oak tree but yeah so it's showing
that
you can have this whole apparatus and
this abstraction
but if you trace the words they don't
begin in something abstract
obviously it's not like they begin with
god they actually
begin with a phenomenal interaction with
the world
and then through language becomes
something much more abstract that can be
put to use
in in something like metaphysics so
that's basically the beginning of
metaphysics when we're at the second
metaphor
level when when it loses its origin and
that's the obsession with these
origins and tracing things back right we
we put them back
where they belong almost yeah and i
would even talk about uh just to move
away from language for a second even
though it's really interesting topic
uh somebody who did wasn't afraid of
metaphysics someone like gilda liz right
i think he actually tries to give a
metaphysical interpretation at some
point
uh of what nietzsche was talking about
albeit you know with bergson and
espinoza thrown in
uh because one of the things that you
know says is
there's always been this temptation in
western metaphysics and
even a western practice to want to
eliminate difference right and eliminate
the particularity that we find in
existence
by suggesting that ultimately all things
are god right
you think about like platinus right are
ultimately all things uh
exist in this kind of platonic heaven
and the liz says no you know we should
sit there and appreciate difference in
and of itself
right uh what each thing is or what each
process is
in its specificity without trying to
subsume it uh
under some kind of higher metaphysical
into some kind of higher metaphysical
system
i know you haven't listened to my
podcast with chris
right it's really funny that you're
bringing this up because it was on
exactly this topic
so there's a previous podcast it's on
process metaphysics as you're saying
gilda liz
nietzsche um have a process-based
metaphysics
whereas uh most of western metaphysics
and why heidegger
derrida nietzsche reject western
metaphysics is because it's too based on
substances and particularly these
special
invisible substances it's static right
yeah that's
like what post-structuralism does is it
says it hides the difference
right when we come we wake up one day we
say there's a dog we wake up the next
day we say there's a dog
it introduces this sort of false
continuity
and we lose the differences and where
post-structuralism is focused on
difference and so when you get into
metaphysics
where things have labels things have
names you sort of forget
the difference because each thing
is what it is it is what we called it
yesterday and it will be tomorrow and
that's that this sort of linguistic
argument revolves around this
this kind of and i think that by the way
can you talk about that for just a
second longer because one of my
or one of our i should say one of our
patrons asked me in the message
uh how do you define the the distinction
between
structuralism and post-structuralism and
we're almost there so
if anyone wants to take it yeah yeah
yeah post-structuralism is really about
the uh the so the structure
is a static structure and it produces
phenomenon and the structure is what's
behind the phenomenon and the structure
doesn't change
right so when you have say a linguistic
structuralism
you have a series of words connected
with a series of concepts
and those concepts become part of
binaries right
good and bad man and woman nature and
culture
subject and object and they don't change
but the surface effects change but
that's what we want to get away from in
post-structuralism we don't want to just
say that the surface is what's changing
but the deeper structure
is always the same this is like this is
derrida in 1966
saying i think there's something like an
event
has happened in structuralism and the
event is something new
and structuralism can never account for
something new
because the structure isn't allowed to
change it's a series of cross sections
and how you get from a to b is a mystery
we just know that a is one way
and b is another way and maybe that's a
bad maybe maybe that's a bad way of
explaining it but that that was my
understanding
structuralism is just basically how do
we get from this
this sound that comes out of your mouth
how do you get that
to the world how does the sound of your
mouth saying like
tree obviously we always use the example
of tree but how does tree yeah
mean tree to your to your mind to the
tree outside what is the connection
there
and then there it is arbitrary right so
they make a they make a structure out of
this
and develop a linguistic in this way but
if you want to
to get into that gap this is what
post-structuralism is going to look for
where the gaps exist in what we think
knowledge is
for example or what we think history is
or what we think god is
you're gonna find where that gap is like
a little bit covered over
instead of dealt with properly yeah like
another big quote from nietzsche
is every concept makes something that is
not equivalent equivalent right right
that's that's one of his big quotes and
that's sort of one of the major
drivers behind post-structuralism i
don't know that is that sounds really
good
differences everywhere yeah yeah
yeah i don't know if that's from
nietzsche or if that's just a quote i'm
reading from uh
from somebody like explaining something
important about post-structuralism but
yeah every
every concept hides the differences and
the post-structuralists are all about
the differences
though because like just come back to
like nietzsche's historicity right and
particularly its influence on somebody
like foucault right um
one of the ways that i interpret
structuralism looking at it very broadly
rather than
than just as a linguistic theory uh
pioneered by saucer right
uh the phenomenal world that we
apprehend
can be understood uh with reference to
deeper structures
uh that can be unmasked through
say dialectical analysis right uh via
hegel right or cesarian analysis of the
whole ism of our linguistic life worlds
right
uh and one of the things that the
post-structuralists do like for co
and following from nietzsche is saying
no because the problem is that
you're still trying to eliminate
difference in the world by saying that
while it appears that there's difference
this can all be explained by the
structure
and one example of this that i think
nietzsche picked up on as there can be
this temptation
and marxist theory to say that yes there
are different historical epochs
different ways of organizing economy
different ways that people have produced
things but ultimately they all will wind
up
uh in a capitalist society because
there's a kind of
motion of history or there's a movement
to history uh
and in the end uh we're going to all
wind up in a communist society
right uh yeah that's pretty in the way
that
post-structuralists understood marx
right progress kind of argument yeah and
i think there are people who argued it's
more who argue that marx is more
complicated and we can come back to that
right uh
but you know the post structures really
push against that by saying no don't sit
there and say that
earlier societies uh are just some kind
of way station on the way to
who we are right now right you should
look at these independent societies
understand the logics behind their
thinking and recognize that
they're discreet and interesting in and
of themselves
not just uh as kind of way stations on
the way to
understanding modernity right yeah if
you think that history has a purpose
like any program if you believe in any
kind of progress if you think history
has a purpose
then nietzsche wants to have words with
you because
it's random i mean the whole the death
of god thing
has a lot of meanings and one of them
you should connect this
listener in this patreon episode so
we're talking to the
the nobles not the uh not the unwashed
maps
so you'll probably know about the barth
death of the author
paper and death of the author is an echo
in in the the transition to
post-structuralism
of the death of god right it's the thing
that's
outside of history that guarantees
history's movement towards
some fantastic conclusion whatever it is
you're nailing so the death of the god
is that you know that that position no
longer exists
outside of the rules of the system right
it's the thing that
guides the system but isn't subject to
the rules of the system it's also what
we call the archimedean
point right archimedes says give me one
solid point now lift the whole world
well the death of god is also a kind of
denial
of that third person objectivity there
is none of that when we're talking about
language and history everything's
relative to
these things there's nothing that sits
outside of it
but also determines it that's also
derrida's
argument in a much more sort of i'd say
sophisticated way i don't find nietzsche
very sophisticated
poetically he's brilliant but like in
terms of his thinking
yeah i think heidegger immediately runs
right past it that's what i was going to
say about dary did though i mean one of
the things that he picks up on
um brecht and other people who write
about the death of the author right is
precisely that
uh the problem with structuralism in
some ways part
sorry is that um you know there's this
insistence that
we can still formalize the meaning of a
given term
uh and that's by looking at to a certain
say this historically determined
um the historically given word like role
of a term
uh in a system of science right and once
we understand the system
we understand what that word means uh
and i think it's important to know that
dara did never sits there and says
there shouldn't be things like canonical
interpretations uh that help
inform our disparate interpretations of
a given turn
he's very experienced he doesn't say
there shouldn't be centers yeah he
doesn't say there are no such things
that's exactly it he's very expressed
about that in his 1967 paper right
uh in some senses you need a canonical
interpretation of a term
in order to come up with idiosyncratic
interpretations of it right but he also
does insist that
just because there might be canonical or
more better more well established
interpretations of a word
that doesn't mean that that
interpretation isn't repressing
alternative interpretations or
possibilities that this sign could be
used for
and he says in a very niching vein you
can look back at the history of the way
this world has been used
as a kind of i'll use the draconian term
here because i think it's more
down to earth like archive of different
possible meanings it might have had
that we could theoretically resurrect or
we could be appropriate or we could play
with
uh depending on if we're interested in
doing that and he has a whole host of
examples
that are very interesting right i want
to just stress and stress
because i think we're talking because
we're getting really excited about this
this is like the most important point
the part where like
old philosophy is finished uh
hegel is like the last classical
philosopher and this is where all of the
critical theory stuff comes in so i just
want to say
again um how important this is because
we were talking about hegel
and hegel's got a history and this
history has a purpose that history is to
realize freedom but to have history have
a purpose
that requires this position what eric
called the arc median point you need to
have a position
outside of history that's able to judge
it to be moral about history
um and this is a criticism of marxism
too and the same thing with a book
like if you're going to say this book
has authorial intention
you have to assume there's a position
outside the book
that is giving it that purpose but as
soon as you get rid of god
history's over because history never
started you're outside of history
um and then it's only these little minor
stories that matter anymore there's no
grand narrative we can call
postmodernism the end of grand
narratives
and that's precisely because god is dead
you can't look at history
from outside of it because you're always
in it and there's no
god to like give you his like super
all-seeing eye
from eternity so that you're not stuck
in this problem so all of
all of 20th century philosophy is just
this problem
over and over again in sociology
psychology
linguistics um and people like
the people that we [ __ ] on all the time
logical positives positivists or
jordan peterson they don't want to they
don't want to think this way they don't
want to think that this actually
happened it did happen
nietzsche said it did and it's over you
can't posit these grand narratives
anymore
or just assume that you're
yeah i was going to say victor's right i
mean jordan peterson
absolutely adores nietzsche in fact one
of the weirdest things about him is he's
one of those people who says
well you know we can have our nietzsche
and our grandiose people
uh but we can also have our christian
values too right
we can have we can have nature but trans
people don't real
individualism right that's he's
interpreting he's falling into this
individualist interpretation of
nietzsche
that nietzsche is an ardent
individualist
a heroic individualist he likes
nietzsche because nietzsche emphasizes
the suffering
of life like the [ __ ] that that guy says
about language man he's like
you can't just invent words like [ __ ]
man you read nietzsche you idiot
wow that's harsh but yeah no i was gonna
say i i think
we're all getting this idiot about this
because of the kind of
historical significance of this moment
that i think we're all acknowledging in
a different way right um
and i think just to kind of bring it
back down to earth because we kind of
went
uh a little bit of field into some very
different fields um
this just really testifies to the fact
that uh nietzsche as much as marx
and as probably more than freud by this
point right uh i had
just a profound impact on so many
different fields right
uh it's really he's one of really one of
those figures where if you were to ask
you know explain to me what his
significance would be it'd be almost
impossible
just because so many different people
have picked up on these threads right
he invented sociology basically
like weber directly drew from nietzsche
from this historicist argument he
invented
he invented psychology because freud
develops the unconscious from this uh
wilt of power of like urges
he invented suppressed urges he invented
linguistic analysis at least in the uh
in the continental version because you
know heidegger goes back to all these
terms and try i think heidegger was a
worse philologist than nietzsche but
you know he just kicked off it's hard to
understate
the gravity of this event it's pretty
impressive for an insult
yeah i think i think foucault just like
to really simplify
his foucault's kind of he takes on like
like so nietzsche does good and evil
foucault
does in the history of sexuality he does
male and female
in the history of his in in his prison
book right
discipline and punish he does civ
civilian
and criminal and madness and like
right yeah yeah sane and insane right
like he
he takes that sort of idea that these
binaries have like a history
and he just applies them to different
things right the hospital the prison
and like discourses of the body and
sexual matt did you say not bad for an
incel
i didn't because that's an underrated
underrated joke
yeah no no no but like i was gonna say
um i mean
this is what i find really helpful about
foucault right uh and i don't always
have nice things to say about him but
right like
he really does uh take this project
forward and run with it uh and i think
it was in eight uh 1980 uh somebody
asked him and he's like i am a
nietzschean
right uh and you can really see that
right where he shows a lot of fidelity
to this project
uh but this is actually where i think uh
we should maybe shift towards
a more political dimension just because
i know that we have binary who's coming
on
in two weeks [ __ ] sorry why do i
always say that
um bionic is coming on in two weeks
uh to talk about nietzsche and politics
and one of the interesting things about
nietzsche uh is precisely that you see
people on very different ends of the
political
spectrum finding him appealing right um
people like michelle foucault find him
appealing
there are any number of nietzsche sorry
marxists like terry eagleton who find
them appealing
but so do an awful lot of fascists all
right yeah that spencer guy
yeah richard spencer the nazi party
loved him even though he was he would
certainly not be a nazi yeah by the way
listener what matt's referencing is
the reason we're doing nietzsche and and
heidegger first is because we're
interviewing
an expert in those areas um but we
wanted to establish
i guess our take on it is that what
we're doing i guess so it's kind of a
preparatory episode i guess but only for
the patrons so and it's yeah professor
ronald biener
at university of toronto thank you
victor i [ __ ] up so
but yeah why how how could you
appropriate this for for a right-wing
perspective i mean it's not impossible
it's a lot more easy to appropriate
nietzsche for
right-wing purposes than someone like i
don't know rancier
yeah or martial i mean i did i i did
read some i went back to the genealogy
of morals and i was like what this is
right wing [ __ ]
and then i read it and i was like he
says some pretty [ __ ] up things in
this
like he does he talk he talks about jews
and dark-haired people
quite a bit and he has some like things
to say about that that would not be
acceptable well i mean okay here's uh
here's the i
think i willfully ignored that part
because i don't remember i i
i was talking about jews it's like the
judaist
or judaism uh kind of paradigm world
paradigm
i kind of i do the same thing i do when
i like i'm like oh heidegger wasn't all
that like
because he's kind of saying like jewish
and christian are the same
part i don't think that that part's
really the problematic part if you
if you call like being uh like
right-wing problematic like i think the
problematic part is that
nietzsche is blatantly an
anti-egalitarian and like the fact that
his whole value system
is about like so i would say like if i
was to sum up like
nietzsche's political vision in in like
if i was to simplify it i would say to
some extent
he's like the cultural values of society
have to be those
that that that uncover are the vitalik
the the vitalistic like instincts for
life in like so that the best souls can
be raised to the top
and if that's at the cost of the week
so be it the weak should suffer because
the strong should be the ones because
the the greatness of humanity can only
be
properly uh instantiated if
the the instincts of the culture is
life-affirming in such a way
that those souls who have the best
ability to overcome to self-overcome in
accordance with the will to power
does he they're raised up so that the
weak he
uh so he says in a few places he talks
about how like
the like um the the spirit of a people
have to be
such that they like um that they like ra
that they
they um push the ins the um
the values that can uh create
life-affirming horizons and
life-affirming horizons
are those kinds of things that can like
allow that like deny the weak and like
you know don't like we don't care about
the weak and we care about the ones who
are going to be the noble souls of the
future
at the same time though he was also an
ardent anti-nationalist he said like
being proud of your
being proud of your country is like the
stupidest thing you can do yeah like i
think the
the anti-egalitarian thing is debatable
so i don't think there's any debate
about that i mean no there's no debate
inequality is good like what he seems to
be saying
is that the morality that the weak
created creates a worse kind of enmity
in society than if we just sort of
let the aristocratic values be the
dominant kind of thing
because he's going to say like okay i'll
i'll i'll say his horrible [ __ ]
he's going to say that like jews are the
worst enemies to have
because they hold a grudge and they're
smart about it whereas jesus
he's going to say he's going to say it's
a sign of the strong
that they cannot for long take serious
their enemies
they're going to forgive respect your
enemies because respect is a bridge
to love whereas with enemies of the
say judeo-christian tradition those
enemies are
evil and evil people are damned to hell
and there is like he's he's almost
saying that they are more
in egalitarian than if we could just
take on a more
like if you just wake up remember at the
beginning we were saying like
his his philosophy is shocking like he
wants to shock you
out of your sort of complacency and get
you thinking
and it's to say these values you're
holding
are creating terrible problems in our
society
and if you just look at them and realize
that that's what they're doing
you can actually wake up and be life
affirming
and say [ __ ] your enemies they're my
enemies today but tomorrow they'll be my
friends because i [ __ ] respect them
right like he's not he's not like the
anti-egalitarian thing in nietzsche
okay it seems that way if you take
things out of context and put certain
things together
but i don't think that's the upshot i
don't think it's like he wants an
inegalitarian all right give us
show me where he says i want to add
something to this rebuttal too okay
okay so let me just read this quote here
this is oh god
he's cheating you're cheating you can't
use quotes no no
no come on no no but i mean this is
really telling right where he says the
great majority of men have no right to
life and serve only to discontent the
elect among our race
i do not grant the unfit that right
there are even unfit peoples
right and there are volumes of quotes to
this effect right where he says things
like
the 20th century will be marked by wars
with horror yet unseen upon the earth
and i look forward to it because this
will at least like explicit
uh the kind of morality of the slave by
demonstrating how banal and evil
communism is amongst other things right
so let me just add one more thing to
that too i want to add one more thing to
that which is just that
so i think to give some sort of an olive
branch maybe to the worry of like what
what what maybe what eric is getting at
is like so i
also think that nietzsche would condemn
any
like free any existing fascist movement
that has happened
in in human history like i think he
would look at i don't know nazism and
any of these things and be like you guys
became followers and peasants and like
you weren't really yeah
i agree you weren't really being a
people and a culture that was
life-affirming like you were being some
other [ __ ] like he
so he would be very critical so i'm not
saying he's like a nazi in
that or or like an anti-egalitarian in a
way that resembles any like existing
political ideology
it just means that ultimately he doesn't
care about equality
or like or like making sure that we can
have the best society for the most
number of people quite the opposite in
fact i would say that he wants
the best to rise up and [ __ ] everybody
else who's not contributing to like good
life affirming values
and one one thing that i want to add to
that because it builds right off is
the he he doesn't think that inequality
needs to be
like fixed because he's he actually
thinks that inequality is better
for the people who are oppressed because
when you're oppressed you create better
art
basically you invent dance you invent
literatures
delis picks up on this you you you are
you can laugh more you sing more
um and all the this is back to the
master slave dialectic
the people who are oppressed create
better
stuff right and he's he's especially
uh he's he loves art all kinds of art
dance music and etc
and he says if you're the the or the in
egalitarian system is better for
everybody because the poor make better
art and the rich
get to you know have this mutual and the
best the best souls can rise up
but either way like he's either way
you're going to have
inequality you're not going to be
egalitarian in the sense of like
not everyone's going to be equal but
where you guys i'll just play devil's
advocate a little bit
and say what you guys are saying is that
he is anti-woke and therefore he is
inegalitarian well yes he is anti-woke
he thinks that slave morality
that it's a bad thing when you claim the
massive people
the great majority of humankind has no
right to life i mean
that's not anti-woke right that's
anti-liberal that's
believe in any anti-communist he thinks
rights are just a tool to extreme
strength
and that's what i mean i mean i'm just
saying he would be against any left-wing
like
any left-wing project for like for
social transformation he would be
against
yeah but then he would also be against
any right-wing project
of like i don't think he would be a
supporter of donald trump well that's
right
that's what i was told that was either
that's what i was saying against the
alt-right he would be against the like
woke left he would be
he would almost be a centrist in that
sense well
but he would also be very radical in any
different way political system that he
would be against
well he but he but very much what he
wants though like it's but we can't lose
sight of like what he does say that he
wants
which is for like life-affirming values
that privilege the best souls the soul
and like that is an idea that is
contrary to any left-wing perspective
ultimately and yeah i should also add
it's consistent with his genealogy also
right because he says that
the notion of moral equality and the
universal quality of all human beings
came into the world with christianity
right the triumph of the weak over the
strong
and he sometimes is very explicit about
what he wants as a return
to pre-platonic thinking and this notion
that some people uh are better you know
they're proud achilles
uh who sit there and they tyrannize you
know the weak who are their prey
you know and they're the hawks as you
put it so art i think it's wetlands and
i don't think there's any way you can
give this a kind of egalitarian spirit i
don't think you can i agree but
the point of achilles and respect is
that he doesn't even know
he's oppressing like he doesn't even
have enough attention to pay exactly
poor people
because he's too busy like being great
and
conquering people and fighting age or
whatever absolutely
he's too busy killing hector to care
that someone has to carry his armor for
him right
like he has this whole argument about
like look at how these aristocrats have
such a nuanced language when it comes to
the pitiful when it comes to the
downtrodden when it comes to people
like like achilles or like the people
you see in homer right they have this
very rich
language of pity
in a way and they see people's struggles
as i don't know he has this weird
philological linguistic argument that
says well look how rich their language
for the pitiful is
and look how simple the languages
of the judeo-christian heard
can you give an example all right there
i was looking for the quote
i can't find it right now if i find it i
will i'm saying it's so hard today
which is just him describing i mean it's
it doesn't exactly
speak to this but it's just him
describing the highest kind of person in
the gay science
so i uh he says a person whose horizon
encompasses thousands of years past and
future
being the heir to all heir of all
nobility of all past spirit and heir
with a sense of obligation
the most aristocratic of old nobles and
at the same time
the first of a new nobility the likes of
which no age has yet seen or dreamed of
if one can burden one's soul with all of
this the oldest the newest
losses hopes conquests and the victories
of humanity
if one could finally contain all this in
one soul and crowd it into a single
feeling
this would surely have the results in a
happiness that humanity has not known so
far
that's pretty impressive but that does
definitely make the point that is what
he's looking for is like an aristocratic
yeah cast or a cabal whatever you want
the best characterize it
uh like you want it's definitely it's
definitely not a nationalistic vision i
completely
see it it certainly doesn't resemble any
right-wing movements that exist today
like he
he's against like peasant like like
idiots
so like i think he'd be a good buddy but
my only claim would just be like
to to try to co-opt him for as like on
the left is just wrong like because like
insofar as the left entails some form of
egalitarianism
if you compare this to hegel because
both of them both of them speak
favorably of someone like napoleon right
but hegel's reasons for
uh extolling napoleon is he's bringing
reason
he's bringing law he's bringing
uniformity he's creating a state
whereas nietzsche's reasons for loving
napoleon are like napoleon wakes up
and because he's so powerful he has this
drive in him he just got to go conquer
[ __ ]
he's he's doing this it's like an
artistic process his art is
battle and conquest whereas
yeah that's why he was a he was a
throwback to the old
roman and greek arabic and then you put
him on prison and then he gets out of
prison and he does it one more time he
just
he can't be held back so so we haven't
really touched on this term yet but
resentment risante ma
right and nietzsche right and what he's
saying is that if we lived in a society
where noble values were dominant there
wouldn't be groups of people resenting
one another
he says that the noble man feels
resentment but
it's absorbed in his instant reaction to
it and it doesn't
poison him as in it he doesn't nurse
this
grudge against some other group of
people but the slave morale
morality the so-called egalitarians they
look at people who are inegalitarian
and they say these people are evil these
people are wrong and these people need
to die and they nurse this grudge they
don't have this immediate release
because they go to their secret places
in their secret gardens that are just
their own worlds
and they nurse these sorts of feelings
or they try to get away from them
and then they come back to the real
world and they come back to these
feelings because they have
no respect for the people they don't
like
like you were talking about compassion
compassion would be
having respect for the person that
you're arguing against
like what is a woke person screaming
racist screaming misogynist screaming
you're oppressing me like where's the
respect
in that way of arguing with somebody
where's the compassion
it's gone because it's absorbed in the
poison
of the slave morality which just erases
all respect for your enemies
wendy brown has a really good critique
of this in her book uh in the ruins of
neoliberalism right well she's talking
about
the kind of alt-right interpretation of
nietzsche and she's very fond of
nietzsche i should say like i am and
like i think all of us are
uh in a certain sense right uh but one
of the things that she points out is
that
if you look at the kind of examples
nietzsche gives uh it's almost always
about resentment right
uh he's almost always talking of the
resentment of the weak against the
strong
and he never actually talks of the kind
of resentment that the strong can feel
towards the weak
uh except to downplay it in the way you
just described and one of the things she
says is
if you look at politics in the
contemporary era people like donald
trump
how can you describe that except as the
resentment of the strong towards the
weak right the idea that
this is my society people like me built
it
uh i have all kinds of money and power
associated with me
and how dare all of you think that you
are entitled to any of that
right uh and i think this is a really
pretty compelling argument and one of
the things she castigates nietzsche for
uh is not taking into account the idea
that sometimes the nobility
especially when they're looking at the
downtrodden and when the downtrodden are
trying to stand up to them
uh it can be very easy for them to feel
resentment also and say well no i earned
this
all of you are just a bunch of layabouts
who are only the beneficiaries of
the values and the wealth and the and
what the civilization i created uh and
you should all just shut up and go back
to your place
right and i think that's something he
doesn't really talk about that much
i think that's right and i'm i'm just
i'm getting passionate
trying to make take nietzsche seriously
but i think you're right
that yeah obviously nietzsche isn't
taking seriously how much it
sucks to be the downtrodden and how like
psychologically
[ __ ] that would be to the point where
like how can you really respect the
people
who are keeping you in this position but
let me let me just cheat again and i'll
say like here's the two versions
here's the aristocratic bad and here is
the
here is the evil of the slave morality
he says he says the bad of the
aristocrats is just a byproduct
a complementary color almost an
afterthought whereas the evil
of the slaves is the beginning the
original creative
act of slave ethics he says
saying no is the original creative act
of the slave
it's saying no to another whereas it's
almost like he's saying the yes and
thing about the nobles the nobles are
always like yes and
like yes good but
i disagree with you like he's almost
giving it like
that's the original act like that's like
this is almost
i take this almost as a fiction and i
don't i think it's complete [ __ ]
it's almost metaphysical in itself but
just taking it seriously for a second
and saying
that the evil of slave morality the one
that we're dealing with today
in our society which is so degenerate
and horrible
is that it's against
other people it's a primary
originary thing whereas the bad of
someone who's
got an aristocratic mind and a great
temperament the bad there is just sort
of an afterthought it's like oh [ __ ] i
failed to be good
so i guess that was bad and i guess i'll
try again later
i don't know uh but brown has a really
poignant example in her book uh that i
found very resonant because i was living
in mexico at the time
uh when you know i read this and she
said if you don't believe that the
powerful can have resentment towards the
poor
uh just be a relatively privileged
person not even a very powerful person
uh go walk in the street in a poor area
of the city
uh and look at a beggar and when the
baker asks you for money
ask yourself what feeling is it that i
have right
uh because probably the instinctual
thing that you'll have when the beggar
asks you for money
is revulsion uh followed by why do i
have to be bothered during my day
uh i didn't do anything that is that
means this person is poor
uh i worked hard for my money and all
these kinds of feelings right
uh and she says this is the kind of
resentment that we feel towards the weak
if we're in a privileged position
all the time uh because we don't like be
remind being reminded
of the frailty of human existence and we
don't like being reminded of the fact
that
there but for the grace of god would i
go and so
we hate the people that expose us to
this reality quite consistently
and one of the things that she says
about nietzsche is nietzsche had a lot
of very
insightful things to say about the
problems with how it is that the wounded
uh or the victimized can feel resentment
and create bad and malicious systems on
that basis and she wrote a whole book on
that called when wounded attachments but
he seems to have very little sympathy
uh for as you you know pointed out you
know the downtrodden right and the
resentment that they might justify i
believe i'm sorry
uh and the resentment that they might
not uh be the victims of continuously
from the people who've appointed
themselves their betters
right yeah it's it's hard to separate
the sort of
idea that like slave morality is a whole
metaphysical system of ethics
versus like just being in that moment
and feeling pity for somebody
or even like being in in that moment and
you're the privileged one and just being
sort of
generally annoyed that they exist i mean
it's hard to separate
you're right it is like nietzsche's
giving us a kind of
convincing fiction here that there's a
lot of holes in and
yeah like where does okay so maybe maybe
nobility
is doomed and slave morality is just
going to be the new norm
so then where where does compassion fit
in there
and nietzsche is pretty pretty uh pretty
pessimistic about
there being like a true sense of
morality
in in a society that we're in today
because we're
again we're splintered into these groups
and we think everyone else is evil
and you can see it online when someone
disagrees with you they become the enemy
immediately
and not the enemy that you have respect
for that you want to fight
that you want to that you want to be
your enemy but the enemy that needs to
be destroyed the enemy that
is the real the the evil one
in all caps no yeah i think that's 100
true right and
i actually i've never thought about
applying that kind of niche and analysis
to online discourse so
well we've we're recording for over an
hour and a half now by the way
i have a winding thought and i think it
ends up there but i think i'm just gonna
start talking and see if it gets me
there
so the objection that the the
aristocratic values are not reflective
like they don't
they don't have compassion they don't
put themselves in someone else's mind
and go oh you're suffering okay because
they're too busy doing their own thing
so they don't resent the poor because
they're reminded of like
human frailty they just don't like the
poor because the poor are dirty
it's like completely aesthetic and
effective to them
the reason that they don't like seeing
weakness
and grossness it's just like you're
gross i'm not even going to think about
what you're thinking
so i think in that case they don't think
about them at all yeah in that sense
in that sense like trump trump has
nothing like aristocratic values because
he's a resentful [ __ ]
and like he's just demanding affirmation
all the time
whereas the aristocratic value person
never needs affirmation from anybody
because they know their strength and
they know their worth
so without bringing this into like a
class
uh thing just the way that you argue
with people
i think you probably can point to people
in your lives or all of us could
um there's this kind of like water off
the back people that don't need to store
up resentment and they don't need to
destroy because they're too busy
creating and too busy being life
affirming as nietzsche says
rather than life denying and then
there's also that
cast of people whether or not it has to
do with class or or not
that want to punish others and want them
to feel that pain and punishment and
they're going to
keep going at whatever they're going at
until someone else feels that way
there might be there might be some truth
to that but i i i i think you're right
that that's
how i read nietzsche too like i remember
that whole analogy with the hawk
eating the mouse or whatever it's like
it's not that the hawk feels no
resentment it's just like this is just
i'm just doing me i'm being me
it's like i'm not thinking about you at
all it doesn't have anything it doesn't
hate the mouse it's just like
it's just like i'm just being a [ __ ]
badass that i am and like
not thinking about anything else right
and i think that's true but like this is
kind of where like when i think about
like the highest values
you know where i feel like like
nietzsche's maybe like in-cell
ism comes in because it's just like he's
thinking about these
these these artistic creative souls who
are up there not thinking about
anybody else and like this is just my
own personal like reaction right whereas
like i think when i think of like the
best people i think of someone who's
like magnanimous who like is doing cool
stuff
but is also like in touch and connects
with other human beings i think that's
like an aspect that somehow
like nietzsche because he's such an
insult like forgets about like the value
of being like a magnanimous the paradox
here
everything nietzsche talks about he does
the opposite he spends
all of his books whining about
christianity whining about democracy
whining about communism whining about
the weak
like whatever he's pointing to is not
him because
an aristocratic value person would not
sit there writing those books they would
just go do the stuff that they're
talking about
exactly i have a fun i have a fun quote
all right you you go first matt then
i've got i've got well i was gonna say
uh
this is actually a kind of entry point
where i jump in with like uh
these kind of weird christian
interpretations of nietzsche right
because there have been actually
intelligent christian authors who tried
to
respond to him by pointing out the kind
of distinctive characteristics of jesus
right and they said that
in the gay science you know nietzsche
talks about this person who can kind of
combine
all history in his being uh probably
almost invariably he right
and will noble values uh and one of the
things that i pointed out by people like
nikos kazantakis in the last temptation
of christ is
well think about jesus right here's
somebody who took all human suffering
uh on his shoulders understood it
empathized with it
uh and nonetheless was able to carry on
in a very heroic way
uh in spite of bearing everyone's so
jesus
jesus isn't a cuck yeah well this is the
kind of argument they make like
doesn't this have a kind of heroism and
a kind of glory to it
that's undervalued by somebody like
nietzsche doesn't also
link jesus in some way holistically with
the rest of the world
uh in a sense that nietzsche would be
disconnected or the nietzschean superman
would be disconnected
since he doesn't have any kind of sense
for what's going on in the mind of the
sheep
right uh he's only concerned with doing
him and being a badass
right uh and i think there's a lot to
that argument um
even if we secularize it well he he like
there's a problem with saying that like
nietzsche
like here's here's a quote i'll say what
was jesus but temptation
in its most sinister form and
irresistible form
bringing men by a roundabout way to
precisely those jewish
values and renovations of the ideal
that's what he says about jesus too so
he clearly doesn't have an unambiguously
positive view of jesus no again he goes
back
he thinks he's a trap but i also have a
fun quote okay so you have slave
morality and aristocratic morality let's
change that to uh
wokeness slave morality and privilege
aristocratic so what happens okay so
here's here's nietzsche let's articulate
this new claim
we need a critique of all wokeness the
intrinsic
worth of wokeness must first of all be
called into question
to this end we know the conditions from
which those values have sprung and how
they developed and have changed
hitherto such knowledge has been a
dessert a decision point
the intrinsic worth of wokeness was
taken for granted as a fact of
experience and put beyond question
nobody up to now is has doubted that
wokeness represents a higher value and
that privilege
in terms of promoting and benefiting
mankind generally
even taking the long view is evil
but suppose that the exact opposite were
true what if
wokeness represents not merely a
retrogression but even a danger
a temptation a narcotic a drug enabling
the present to live at the expense of
the future
more comfortable less hazardous perhaps
but also
baser more petty so that wokeness itself
would be responsible for man as a
species failing to reach the peak of
magnificence for which he is capable
isn't that a cool way to read nietzsche
in terms of like yeah i know that one
is that was amazing could you actually
do me a favor and like
like transcribe that quote and like like
give me a page reference and i don't
know if you don't mind like like just uh
because i'd love to just have that i
want it like i want to share that if you
we're taking pictures take a picture
section
six of the of section six of the preface
to genealogy of morals
could you just like take a photo of it
and uh or something anyway so there is
this like
there is this critique right the
critique is fair
um and how much does it apply i don't
think we have really time to get into
that but
like we're way over time here i think
kind of well it's good for a long one
this is nietzsche's gotta be long
um this is just
just so twitter right it's punish
and publicly punish and publicly bring
down
um and that's not all awokeness is
obviously there's like good intentions
as well in
in critiquing privilege and things that
are valuable
but like the public flogging kind of
thing would cancel culture kind of thing
what we were we have an episode on that
um and it
this i think
it it just nietzsche's system if we're
gonna just
clean it out is saying like don't be so
concerned
with everybody else get concerned with
yourself
rise above like fraying clean your eyes
above punishing oh god
am i sound like peterson [ __ ] being a
goddammer
no but i mean it's a good just piece of
like life advice
right get get get out of trying to uh
clean your room before you go and
critique the world i get i guess that's
what he's just saying that's gotta be
it
yeah this is like you can go through uh
you can go through marx's text
and replace uh replace oh [ __ ] i forget
you can go through his text
and replace um yeah proletariat
with uh western european values
and you can and it reads differently
you can do the same with nature replace
replace all the words where he says
like good but where he's talking about
what's good from the perspective of the
slave
replace that with woke and replace bad
with privilege
and it's a completely different text and
it makes like
weird sense well you could apply this
slave morality to something like white
nationalism
also which is just as infantile and
resentful
of of you know oh yeah yeah people that
people seem to be getting something that
you're not getting right
yeah that's the hard part they would
need another thing it wouldn't be like
wokeness and privilege
for them it would be like yeah it would
be like egalitarian they'd be like [ __ ]
these egalitarians you think goodness is
egalitarian or diversity
it would be i don't know it would be
like white nationalism and diversity
diversity yeah cultural diversity would
be their bad
yeah diversities are strengths good
would be
uh good would be nationalist
yeah for them but it might work the same
way and it's interesting to read very
very interesting anyway guys so we uh
wrap this up or with final thoughts
oh my god yeah i just want to say i
think that
nietzsche sometimes to characterize
himself as an untimely person right
uh that his time had yet to come and i
think our conversation here
if nothing else has shown that uh well
over a hundred years after his death
his time very well may have come since
all of us have very different takes
on what's valuable in his work uh but we
all seem to think that he's a super
interesting guy
because we're now 145 minutes into this
i'm sorry an hour and 45 minutes into
this and there's no stopping
there's still a lot to say for sure yeah
um i guess i'll just say that this is i
want to reiterate like i think
maybe now by the end of the episode
patrons you can see why
20 year olds would be so attracted to
this and uh
figure of this figure yeah i know even
though i just as we finished saying how
much we respect him but yeah obviously
you can see all the aspects of him that
make him so attractive i mean it's f in
some ways i feel like nietzsche is like
very punk rock it's like a punk rock
philos for [ __ ]
bad asses and like also very not
sticking to anything like very
masculine too right he exercises
like what about what about a mother is
like will to power
or he calls truth because you can't
[ __ ] understand it he calls truth a
woman that needs to be dominated
it is kind of the shock rock well yeah
truth well that's
that's a machiavelli quote actually
actually no you're right you're right my
mistake nietzsche says that truth
is a woman and every philosopher who
thinks he's been able to like get her is
an idiot and she's gonna like get
she's gonna escape his grasp every time
he tries there's a little bit of
projection there
yeah is like very much in keeping with
like a niche in aesthetics because i
just want to point out that
it's had like gigantic highs and huge
lows like about an
a one hour and we were basically talking
about nietzsche as if he was like the
greatest guy
ever being like any pioneered this and
he pioneered that and you know
this wouldn't have existed without him
and then like 20 minutes later we were
like he's a [ __ ] nazi and you know
what i mean is in egalitarian
orientation
it's just so and it really testifies to
the fact that whatever else you want to
say he was a complicated guy
and he wanted to get a rise out of
people like a punk rock worker would and
he did
right yeah yeah i think i think looking
forward
to uh where we maybe evaluate whether or
not nietzsche
is a so-called like dangerous mind
or dangerous author i mean i think after
reading
genealogy and morals again i think like
i agree you shouldn't read him without
some kind of guidance about like
i don't know from your priest you
shouldn't don't believe
yeah i don't know guidance from a
religious leader maybe
just a philosopher like you shouldn't
believe him too much at first
until you get more of a a picture of the
whole
i mean yeah i can see how the things he
says are very inflammatory
and can be construed in very
horrible ways but
i mean ultimately i don't think there's
an easy thing like what did nietzsche
think
i don't know it's not it's not an easy
question answer but
yeah i think there are some dangers to
the ways that nietzsche
and just the appeal his sort of poetic
style has like everybody wants to read
someone who
says truths but also in the most
beautiful way possible in the most
badass way
yeah and nietzsche does that very well
it's it's kind of like if you say i'm
being nichian because i'm being so epic
then just by saying that you're not
being nichian because the
actual the actual over man would never
even know that he's an over man everyone
else would know it
it's kind of like it's like that paradox
with hipster dumb it's like as soon as
you admit you're a hipster you're not a
hipster
that's true yeah all right well thanks
for taking this ride with us
uh i i would be impressed if you
finished the whole thing um
and we'll see how you edit it down well
i gotta
i think it was pretty like coherent on
it on its own i don't know it was quite
coherent i think so much
anyway thank you for being patreons we
hope you appreciate
this uh extension of our will to power
and i hope you don't resent us for
anything we may have said well as we as
eric already said you guys
are the are the the aristocrat the
aristocracy in our
yeah you know there are nobles anyway
i love you you bunch of eagles yeah
that's good i i've had a couple beers so
i'm gonna go
indulge my will to piss so i'll be back
okay or should we sign up now all right
guys see ya thanks for coming
peace
[Music]
you